لا يبدو الغرب اليوم اقل حماسه ونصره
لاسرائيل منه يوم شنت حربها على غزه فبم
وافقه دوله وتاييد قتلت اسرائيل واصابت
الالاف من سكان القطاع محيله مشهد غزه الى
كارثه انسانيه هي الاشد فضعه في تاريخ
الصراع مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وهي الجريمه التي يتحاشى الغرب
رؤيتها هولوكوست اخر وحرب اباده ضالعا
فيها الغرب ضلوع
اسرائيل يعقد الاتحاد الاوروبي اجتماعا
لوزراء خارجيته لاتخاذ موقف موحد من حرب
اسرائيل على غزه فياتي الموقف الالماني
يصد على الاخرين كل باب الى مراجعه
التاييد الاعمى لاسرائيل
ورافضا اي وقف للحرب لاسباب انسانيه تقول
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه ان من حق
اسرائيل الدفاع عن نفسها ولن يكون هناك
سلام وامن لاسرائيل
والفلسطينيين الا اذا تمت مكافحه الارهاب
وهو ما يعني ان تستمر الحرب على قطاع غزه
دون مسائله ولا دعوه لوقفها وقد سارت دول
مثل النمسا وجمهوريه التشيك على مذهب
المانيا في تاييد اسرائيل اما اسبانيا
وبلجيكا وهولندا وايرلندا فقد بدت اكثر
انفتاحا على دعوه الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو
لوقف الحرب على غزه لاسباب انسانيه جوزيب
بوريل يظل وحده متسقا مع ضميره الانساني
داخل المجموعه
الاوروبيه اعتقد ان ما افهمه هو ان
الوزراء يدركون ان توقف الاعمال العدائيه
هو ضروري بما في ذلك لاغراض دخول
المساعدات الانسانيه الى
غزه وكان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قد د
اجتماع يوم الاحد ضم خمس دول كبرى في
المعسكر الغربي هي فرنسا والمانيا
وايطاليا وبريطانيا وكندا اكدوا فيه دعمهم
لاسرائيل وحقها في الدفاع عن نفسها
والتفسير العملي لعباره الدفاع عن النفس
هو منح اسرائيل الحق في ان تقتل كما تشاء
وقد عبر الزعماء الغربيون عن حرصهم على
منع اتساع رقعه الصراع اي ان تبقى المحرقه
في غزه لا تعدوها الى غيرها كما اكدوا
سعيهم من اجل تسهيل مهمه ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى سكان القطع وهنا يرى
المتابعون ان هذا السعي ينطوي على مغالطه
كبرى اذ كيف تحرص الولايات المتحده ومن
معها على توفير الغذاء والدواء للناس في
غزه ثم تعطي الاذن لاسرائيل
بقتلهم المنطق هنا ضحيه اخرى من ضحايا
الحرب في غزه العرب ايضا كانت لهم
انشغالاتهم بالحرب على غزه لكنهم لا
يملكون الاراده ولا الجراه للتعبير عن
موقف داعم للمقاومه رافض وصفها بالارهاب
ناظر الى فعلها في سياق شرعيه نضال حركات
التحرر من الاستعمار انفضت قمه القاهره
التي انعقدت السبت الماضي دون بيان ختامي
وقد شهدت مشاركه غربيه جد متواضعه وكانت
مصر قد ارادت تحقيق حشد دولي يقدم مقاربه
جديده للصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني لكن
مستوى مشاركه الغرب في القمه كان يقول كل
شيء فقد بعثت امريكا بالقائمه باعمال
السفير الامريكي في القاهره
لحضورها وتفرغ شمل العربي دون بيان الا من
موافقتهم على بيان للرئاسه المصريه يدعو
لوقف الحرب ربما كان مطلوبا من العرب في
قمتهم تحقيق النصره في حدها الادنى وهو
الضغط من اجل ايصال الطعام والدواء الى
المدنيين لا شيء من ذلك
حدث وحيده تخوض غزه حروبها اليوم كما كانت
تفعل دائما وما من نصير فجو ها العربي
يبدو منقسما ما بين متعاطف باضعف الايمان
وبكثير من الكلام لا يجدي ومتفرق غير معني
بما يحدث الا بمقدار كون الحرب تص عيدا
يجب ان ينتهي الى تهدئه وبين شامت يحمد
انه ليس معهم عاكف على عقم عمليه سلام
يستولد فلا تلد الا ازمه بعد ازمه في
المشروع الوطني الفلسطيني على نحو ما ارته
السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه فلا هي دوله
كشان الدول ولا هي مقاومه وحيده تحصي
ضحاياها غزه وحيده تتلقى حمم القصف من
اسرائيل التي تقصف وتقتل وتبيد وتشرد فلا
يراها العالم الا ضحيه لا دوله غاصبه
للارض محتله وفق القانون الدولي وهو واحد
ممن قتلت اسرائيل في هذه الحرب الذين
تقتلهم اسرائيل اليوم في غزه هم ابناء
الذين هجرتهم عام
48 وهؤلاء تريدهم اسرائيل
ودعيني في جوارها فاذا ثاروا من اجل
استعاده ارضهم صنيع الاوكرانيين سارعت
اسرائيل الى دمغهم بالارهاب وردد من
ورائها كورال غربي ارهاب ارهاب ارهاب
فاسرائيل في عين الغرب دائما كانت ضحيه
ارهاب فلسطيني يهدد
وجودها الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه ليست
مشهدا تراجيديا للفرجه المتخف من ثقل
المسؤوليه عنها انها نذير بحريق كبير في
المطقه قد لا يسلم منه من ظن انه بمامن
منه هل يلتقط العرب قبل الفلسطينيين
الفرصه الكامنه في الحرب لفرض القضيه
الفلسطينيه بعزم وحزم كعز الغرب وحزمه في
نصره اسرائيل فانهم ان لم يسارعوا الى
حلها اليوم سارعت اليهم غدا بالتبعات
الثقال